[Music]
they're in this show the grinder now and
the grinder is very good show and the
Critics Choice Award all right
yes grinder got the Critics Choice Award
and there's a lot of well wait you got
the Critics Choice sorry yeah you trying
to be generous showing but yes we all
win we all win after you made it clear
that they didn't anyway you won the
Critics Choice Award there's a lot of
Emmy buzz because people love you and
you're playing yourself you're playing
Timothy Olyphant
on the show the grinder what's it like
to play yourself how do you feel about
that I think that you know a lot of
times Conan you just show up and you say
the lines I guess I should probably feel
guilty about this sometimes you just
show up you say the lines you go home
right you know I mean you don't really
put that much into it and but this one
this role I really would have been
researching it for four years yeah
uh-huh and a lot of time you know who
that guy is
yeah like deep deep deep yeah yeah I
mean I really I really spent a lot of
time with it and really really asked a
lot of questions about what makes him
tick and what really you know I mean
sure and then you know and I don't
usually do this and I sometimes kind of
laugh at scoff at actors you do but like
if someone came up to me off-camera like
craft service and they're like hey bud
and I'm like notes I'm in character
call me Timothy or Tim I never broke I
did the voice Wow and you know people
say oh do you how do you do it you when
you go home like when I was we were
shooting like Deadwood or something he's
like oh does that does that come home
with you is that hard to kind of brush
that off and say no it's piece of cake
but this one it did it came home
hard to shake that Tim all it's hard to
shake it now here's the question yeah is
it a character or are there bladder is
fictional aspects today well that's a
curious question because I said I was
going to work and and they say you know
we're going to do the scene today where
your character shows up and you're
you're gonna date rob lowes characters
the girl that he loves mm-hmm and I said
well this is a little bit of an issue
because I'm playing Timothy Olyphant and
Timothy olive has been married for 25
years yeah 25 years and you have a
lovely wife and a great family who's
your boss that's okay separated
separated for fifteen of them really
good we had a long sort of bumpy part
yeah yeah it was hard on the kids but we
came back together celebrate the
anniversary that I think we can apply so
they said I said look Tim of the ovens
Mary's been married for a long time
having married kids and you've got him
showing up and he's gonna have this
affair with this girl's fling and that's
not really me and they say that they
said that's not the way we see the
character and I said I'm listening you
know I actually said to my wife at one
point I was like oh we okay with this I
mean she's like Tim nobody takes this
seriously so it was so cool I'm
keeping her at least I'm trying like
you're trying you're a better
you